y
[Música]
tras aprobar el cargo de incitar a la
insurrección contra donald trump el
lunes los demócratas piden su
destitución a través de la enmienda 25
si no se produce su salida hoy lo que
parece poco probable la cámara de
representantes- desencadenará mañana un
histórico segundo juicio político en el
senado
la administración de donald ton volvió a
incluir a cuba en su lista de estados
patrocinadores del terrorismo entre los
que se encuentran siria irán y corea del
norte lo que conlleva nuevas sanciones
estadounidenses la isla había sido
retirada en 2015 durante la mejora de
las relaciones bilaterales en la
presidencia de barack obama con la
decisión el canciller cubano denunció
oportunismo político de trump
otra variante de el coronavirus fue
detectada en japon fue descubierta en
dos adultos y dos niños llegados el 2 de
enero provenientes de brasil al país
asiático no se ha podido determinar si
es más contagiosa o peligrosa que las
detectadas en reino unido y sudáfrica
hola como estan buenos dias en américa
latina' y ustedes que nos siguen por la
señal de france 24
bienvenidos a las noticias aquí con
nosotros en france 24 y empezamos en
eeuu donde hay un plazo límite que los
demócratas dan a donald trump para que
salga del poder la cámara de
representantes planea votar mañana la
acusación al mandatario saliente por
incitar una insurrección violenta a
menos que renuncie o que su vice
presidente mike pence invoqué en el
plazo de un día la enmienda a 25 una ley
nunca antes utilizada que permite a la
mayoría del gabinete quitar al
presidente del poder si ya no puede
cumplir con los deberes de la oficina
esto mientras sigue la preocupación por
la seguridad durante la toma de posición
de joe biden como presidente el 20 de
enero el fbi alertó que hay indicios que
podría haber un levantamiento nacional
de simpatizantes de donald trump así
como un nuevo intento de asalto al
capitolio nacional y contra los 50
capitolios estatales las autoridades se
están preparando medidas adicionales de
seguridad que se aplicarán de manera
anticipada
ya de por sí va a ser una toma de
posesión distinta debido a la pandemia
pero ahora hay temores de que washington
puede hacer una vez más escenario de
violentos enfrentamientos atendiendo al
llamado de las autoridades locales y
antes de presentar su renuncia en la
tarde de este lunes el secretario
interino de seguridad nacional chat wolf
anunció que el dispositivo de seguridad
estará listo antes de lo planeado a la
luz de los eventos de la semana pasada y
el programa de seguridad de cara a la
toma de posesión así como la
recomendación del director de servicios
secretos james murray e instruido al
servicio secreto de eeuu para que
empiece las operaciones de seguridad
nacional especial federal para la toma
de posesión de 2021 el miércoles 13 de
enero en vez del 19 de enero a la alerta
que lanzó en días pasados la alcaldesa
de washington merrill de bowser se ha
sumado el gobernador de maryland temen
por que se repita una escena que no se
veía desde hace más de dos siglos la
toma violenta de la sede del congreso y
muchos de nuestros departamentos de
policía y de todo el estado y la guardia
nacional siempre han estado involucrados
en las tomas de posesión esta es
obviamente una cita
mucho más grave ya tenemos alrededor de
500 miembros de la guardia nacional en
la ciudad hemos reforzado nuestra
presencia policial y creo que enviaremos
varios cientos de guardias más
fernández ante las advertencias del fbi
y de posibles protestas armadas en la
capital la guardia nacional autorizó el
envío de hasta 15 mil tropas incluso se
prohibirá que los turistas visiten el
monumento a washington al menos hasta el
24 de enero según el buró de
investigaciones hechos de violencia
similares estarían planeando pse en los
50 capitolios estatales de cara a la
posición del nuevo presidente
joe biden dice que el tema de su
inauguración será la unificación del
país y asegura no tener miedo de tomar
juramento en exteriores como es
costumbre y en una señal que no se rinde
donald trump visitará este día la
frontera entre texas y méxico por la
construcción del muro fronterizo a lo
que algunos señalan esta visita del
presidente saliente como un gesto
agónico de la que fuera su principal
promesa de campaña según uno de los
portavoces de la casa blanca
de ayer se han construido unos 640
kilómetros del muro
durante su gobierno la frontera entre
ambos países tiene una extensión de unos
tres mil 145 kilómetros
y el mismo funcionario cuya dimisión se
hizo efectiva sería la tercera renuncia
de la administración trump tras el
asalto al capitolio en esta oportunidad
el funcionario de que les mencionó es
chat wolf el secretario interino de
seguridad nacional quien se convirtió en
el tercer miembro del gabinete de donald
trump en whittier después de la
violencia del 6 de enero en su cargo
wolf era responsable de los servicios
secretos y anunciaba que los procesos de
verificación para la inauguración se
adelantarán una semana
twitter anunció que eliminó unas 70.000
cuentas ligadas al movimiento activaron
un movimiento conspirativo de extrema
derecha usadas por muchos simpatizantes
de donald trump lo que se suma a las
medidas de la red social tras el asalto
al capitolio twitter elimino el viernes
la cuenta personal de donald trump esta
red social era la principal herramienta
de comunicación del presidente saliente
donde interactuaba con sus 88 millones
de suscriptores
en otros temas el canciller cubano bruno
rodríguez denunció un oportunismo
político por parte de la administración
de donald trump tras la decisión de
incluir nuevamente a cuba en la lista de
países patrocinadores del terrorismo
lista de la que había sido retirada en
2015 la medida complicará los intentos
de un nuevo acercamiento con la isla por
parte de la entrante administración de
joe wright
de regreso a la lista de países que a
ojos de washington apoyan el terrorismo
cuba acaba de unirse de nuevo a siria
irán y corea del norte en el poco
prestigioso listado a tan sólo nueve
días del fin de la administración de
donald trump con esta medida de nuevo
hacemos responsable al gobierno de cuba
y mandamos un claro mensaje el régimen
castrista debe acabar con el apoyo al
terrorismo internacional y con la
subversión de la justicia estadounidense
barack obama había sacado a cuba de
dicha lista en el año 2015 que había
lanzado una nueva era en las relaciones
bilaterales entre otros enemigos desde
la guerra fría pero desde su llegada al
poder
trump fiel a la línea del partido
republicano y a la electoral de la
comunidad cubanoamericana de florida no
ha dejado dar marcha atrás puso fin a
los cruceros entre los dos países en
2019 en septiembre anunció nuevas
sanciones
vamos a restringir aún más las
importaciones de alcohol y tabaco de
cuba nada sorprendente resulta que el
presidente saliente quiere evitar al
máximo las posibilidades de un nuevo
acercamiento entre washington y la
habana antes de abandonar el cargo algo
que ha generado rabia entre los cubanos
principalmente la del canciller bruno
rodríguez condenamos la hipócrita y
cínica calificación de cuba como estado
patrocinador del terrorismo anunciada
por eeuu el oportunismo político de esta
nación es reconocido por todo el que
tenga una preocupación honesta ante el
flagelo del terrorismo y sus víctimas
queda por saber si joe biden estará
dispuesto a un nuevo giro de 180 grados
como lo invitó a hacer los homólogo
cubano miguel díaz canel el pasado 17 de
diciembre méxico expande este día su
plan de vacunación en todo el país las
autoridades de salud dieron a conocer
que se avanzara en la fase de
calibración y ahora se llega a la de
expansión es decir que habrá múltiples
unidades de vacunación en los hospitales
de las 32 entidades esta medida será
posible porque este martes llega a un
embarque
439.000 dosis de fisher el gobierno
mexicano indicó que el total vacunado al
momento es de 87 mil 60 trabajadores
sanitarios una vez concluida la
vacunación del personal de salud
proyectada para finales de enero se
comenzará con adultos mayores
mientras que la ms fue notificada por
japón sobre una nueva variante de el
coronavirus descubierta y el domingo
según el ministerio de salud en cuatro
viajeros que llegaron desde brasil esto
llega solo unos días después de que
tokio y otras tres prefecturas se
impusieran en el estado de emergencia
el coronavirus ha vuelto a mutar una
nueva variante fue detectada en japón en
cuatro viajeros que acababan de llegar
de brasil todavía no está claro que tan
contagiosa es la nueva variante pero se
sabe que tiene ciertas similitudes con
las variantes de reino unido y sudáfrica
el descubrimiento llega sólo unos días
después de que tokio impusiera el estado
de emergencia en respuesta al aumento de
casos hay toques de queda a las 8 de la
noche no obstante el tradicional día del
adulto en japon está previsto para el
lunes cuando se celebrará por aquellos
que cumplen 20 años aquí en kawasaki las
celebraciones tradicionales continuaron
a pesar de las normas soy muy consciente
del riesgo de contagio pero estoy aquí
porque es un evento que pasa una vez en
la vida y es una oportunidad para ver
amigos hay una atmósfera especial que
solo se puede sentir en el lugar y
realmente quería ponerme un kimono por
lo que decidí venir hoy eventos como
este no han sido explícitamente
prohibidos por el gobierno que sí
recomienda que la gente no se reúna en
grupos grandes el primer ministro dijo
que la gente joven esta especie
en riesgo más de la mitad de los nuevos
contagios en tokio están entre menores
de 30 años llegamos al final de esta
emisión les agradecemos mucho su
compañía los invitamos a seguir con
nosotros aquí en france24 ya que se
cuide mucho del copinh 19
[Música]